siete pronti per il finale viene section
regate per vedere uno degli episodi dove
ci si incazza abbastanza facilmente
questo credo sia il massimo che abbia
mai fatto cioè mirage orbiter fatta se
voleva questo livello finale regala non
lo sapremo mai dovete morire due e le
bombe dime allora ce n'è un altro
credibile non è l'ultimo io ci spero
vivamente che sia l'ultimo perché perché
perché mi danno sui nervi ma tanto sui
nervi prove con la voglia di spiegarmi
come dovrei forse ha sì ok ok caos calmi
un cazzo non è così io non ce l'ho
ragazzi l'esasperazione provato un
regalo ci sono trappole però mi cadde
addosso adesso saltare avete pazienza
cos'è quella roba lì vai giù brava eco
perfetto sentite no no non lo sapevo lo
sapevo lo sapevo già giuro che lo sapevo
mi ammazzerò da solo a punto e nervoso
una cosa è impressa in giro e non potete
capire quanto sono in cassa puoi pu par
melo ma perché da non ora non ha senso
neanche mettere tutte ste sentite basta
io non c'è posto veramente chiudo qui i
ragazzi mi farebbe davvero la chiudere
qua è impossibile
cioè una cosa impossibile non so
chiamiamo goku l'onda energetica
facciamo qualcos'altro dai tanto non ci
sono abbastanza trappole mi pare no ok
ok cos'era adesso la mia perché guarda
dove scontato questo potrei io non mi
butto limitato fatto direttamente più
avanti non so già che sanno fare
qualcosa
voglio solo arrivare alla fine voglio
solo arrivare alla fine e poter dire ho
finito sta merda non voglio nient'altro
ok ok regga bene rocce al volo al gol al
volo
minchia che culo certo però che non ho
preso quella che dovevo prendere un alka
la ragazzina sarebbe figo una volta lega
salvifico non morire questo sarebbe
veramente fine sarebbe veramente figo si
è perfetto l'ho preso ce l'ho fatta
mi chiama miracolo è veramente figo
riuscire a fare un livello senza morire
neanche una volta lo so che è
impossibile lo soro alcuno nel mondo ci
sarà riuscito almeno una volta credo che
culo lo sapevo lo sapevo infatti potuto
la stragrande questa in un'altra genio è
vera o giocattolo schivato ok a fermi un
attimo
no niente non c'è e allora non è
possibile se riuscite a trovarli è
troppo le pronunciò ha fatto lo stesso
impossibile allora caminati ok prof e
devo fare in fretta
vai vai no no non c'è ancora non sa chi
o con il primo va lo stesso quello no
non è così non si fosse una volta
arrivato lì non si può saltare
porca [ __ ] perché non ho raga ma non ho
capito niente
ok è bravo un salto dovevi farlo è
difficile 20 e winnie the pooh non
facciamo scherzi qui è perché già sono i
mezzi incazzato quindi no no no no no tu
hai capito un cazzo bravo si è fermato a
deformare no no tu cosa fai
vi sembra normale 2014 dichiarato
ufficialmente guerra gli orsacchiotti
perché mi sono difeso anche come si
passa parte lega perché è semplice devo
statali sulla testa così e poi e poi e
poi deve cadere giù perché sono un collo
ti muovi tessari no no ok se mi è
impossibile mezz'ora ecco lo sapete se
saltano sopra muoio convinto proprio
quindi devo andare tipo più avanti
invece no kat
c'era un po per aggiungerci un po con un
giorno nuovo visto il pareggio che
voglio voglio provare a fare una cazzata
perché so che non ci arrivano sopra che
a farmi attimo
cosa ha fatto perché ho preso questo
cioè noi non volevo fare così devo fare
tipo così se funziona ok questo volevo
farla perché è arrivato un fantasma cioè
ma se io sì si sa la bandiera fermi ai
guai a te se tamas perfetto ammazza
voglia se ti ammazza gli interni che è
fottutamente l'ultimo perché non ce la
posso più fare gioco sono stanco
mentalmente proprio cosa ha fermati
folla di fiera sommato 6 cosa ci fanno
vari precisi di cavalieri dello zodiaco
chiara il forza fino a qui quindi
combatterò per me stesso ok non devo
combattere ragazzi contro un cavaliere
dello zodiaco non so perché lo va a yo
yo uso devo combattere la mente mi ha
anche fatto abbastanza il culo
fantastico ho fatto ragazzi non so non
fatemi domande dopo mezz'ora di
tentativi ce l'ho fatta va bene così
personaggio mi era più scarso di tutti
fantastico ancora page 10 no non voglio
più fare un anno fermi basta non me ne
frega niente non faccio qui una serie
che non posso crederci che si è fatta
così lontano non far taggia che dovevo
recuperare il melone che vedete ragazzi
tutto sto casino e per recuperare un
melone me l'on
io adesso questo me lo porto su cosa
dovevo andare lì sopra credo però si è
pagato ma è meglio così 6 si fa grazie i
bug per una volta mi sono serviti a
qualcosa mandare la tra scala perché mi
niente di più facile stronzate
eccomi sembrare non perché mi sembrava
strano che ci stessi riuscendo davvero
fare arancio la gallina in fa min attimo
ok no eh sì seguire grazie
dov'è il mio premio carmen per
l'intelligenza ah ok perfetto adesso
come cazzo torno su grandissimo e adesso
dovrei tornare indietro per fair mica ce
l'ho fatta non ci posso credere adesso
riesco a morire
no perché meglio che sto già si può fare
si ok se bottari culo perché è perfetto
regalo perfetto queste sono cose cosa è
successo poi su quei cosi veloce ma mio
dio quanto tempo perde si muovi deretano
break perfetto no niente
sì si può andare su non devo andare di
saltare prima
no niente l'esordio giuro non ce la farò
mai più mai più ciò fatta prima volta
poi basta
nonno questo caso un becco so peccato
cosa cosa ho preso o che mio zio
santissimo mezz'ora è ciò che devo
nuotare il suo cast in questo castello
c'è anche l'acqua fantastico
mamma mia se avessi fatto più dietro c
sensi passata in quel buco e vai vai vai
vai perfetto perfetto cosi grandissimo
ok però c'è mio dio
fortunatamente solo fatta ho saltato un
livello a caso l'ho fatto a minchia e
sono riuscito qualche volta non riuscire
a vedere il pavimento è una buona cosa
vuol dire che ce la faccia parte c'è un
pavimento invisibile fantastico devo
andare a cu lo conoscete tutti le mie
botte di culo quindi riuscirò
mi dicono che è leggermente impossibile
fare una cosa del genere o no sì sì
veloce però io odio qualcuno c'ha degli
occhiali a raggi ics o qualcosa del
genere perché non si può non ho fatto
vari ciarla controllo trovato ragazzi
devo andare prima dalla famiglia che ho
capito
vado di qua poi vado no sì sì ok ok
sì
se sì ce l'ho fatta l'ho fatta perché ce
l'ho fatta bassa giovane ha beccato un
caso a caso
meno male che riporto di quasi ha
ringraziato il dio ho vinto o vi basta
ho finito adesso ho finito tutto frega
niente
ok che ho fatto l'ho fatta e sono basse
vi prego ma finale fino a bassa attività
tu sei la [ __ ] che mi ha rubato il
melone maledizione del fatto e arrivare
così lontano ma tu lo hai reali eri
molto male molto male è che ti prende a
bastonate poi vediamo chi dice molto ma
lei scappa apple ha volato via no
ancorato basta cavalieri dello zodiaco
usa questo cos'è che saranno conclusi un
cavaliere dello zodiaco mia penare mai
regalato una navicella spaziale
cos'è sta roba oddio 2000 che cosa sono
già morto non ci avrei mai creduto che
sarei arrivato fino a sto punto fa cosa
e da è da ricordare merda loro brava
brava brava l'aveva pena per la bambina
perfetto veloce veloce non muore però fa
cup royal e vabbè non ce la farò mai
cosa fa cosa fa ma che sei [ __ ] fuori
quanta roba spara stati hai rotto le
balle
ma com'è che io con un colpo muoio alle
cene vogliono 45 non vale come la schifo
sta roba
sì sì ci ho fatto ciò è fatta più
certamente no no mio dio mi ha bruciato
alcuno ma sono vivo ragazzi veloce ma
muori o santiddio money money money
money money money money money money
money money manca poco no no no no
a quanto pare quanto mancava appunto
mancava e manca di nuovo pochissimo
vecchia troya ma perché non possa più
difficile di tutti i livelli messi
insieme di che ho appena fatto ce l'ho
fatta non ci posso credere non ci posso
credere
no no 4 fottute tacche 44 cazzo una
minore race mori muori cazzo una veloce
non muore non muore se mi è arrivato il
melone il mio melone il mio melone il
mio [ __ ] me lo son dovuto andare a
calmarmi reca perché stava morendo giura
una cosa assurda non credevo di
riuscirci giuro non ci posso credere nel
dio se dovrò ricordarmi vito 20 volte
perché è assurdo niente reca comunque se
il video è piaciuto come sony casa
documento mi piace anche a pagliari
facebook e con i video trovate una
descrizione per diversi dischi meccanici
diventiamo un prossimo figo bene ragazzi